what do you guys remember about the
Eastern Orthodox from way back when we
talked about them the first couple
chapters of the book how are they
similar to the Roman Catholics we're
some of the key ideas yeah like
transubstantiation yeah they all have a
mass and they don't they don't use a
term transubstantiation they do believe
that the brat in the wine become
literally the body and blood of Jesus so
liturgy is very important for them what
else do you remember a lot of tradition
right you guys remember the some of the
icons and church councils all that sort
of stuff Eastern Orthodox have a lot in
common with with with Catholics more
than they do with most Protestants and
where are you going to find Eastern
Orthodox in the world where one of the
big areas or ethnicities I'm talking
about that eastern euro all take yeah
okay so we'll put that one out because
that's a that's a play a major role in
the story so Russia um let's see the
Baltic States Rose would be Estonia and
Latvia Lithuania which is Catholic
Eastern Europe in southern Europe right
so Serbia Macedonia Bulgaria Romania all
those are all those are Slavic countries
too we're leaving somebody out that's
that's very important to the story
though yeah very good particularly for
the American part of the story and we
can talk about a few of the Syrians you
know we're also leaving out of this this
part of the story the Oriental north
acts like you know the Coptic and
ethiopians Luthern have a larger goal
through immigration later on so the
Eastern Orthodox how do they end up here
in the United States lot of them end up
coming through Ellis Island like the
Catholics so that you know Greeks would
be doing that a lot of these ethnicities
here in the Russians but the Russians
also got here a different way we come
from further west what is that were they
going to you guys remember that how
people make fun of Sarah Palin for
saying she could see Russia from her
backyard where is Sheila okay yeah great
at least nominally now the issues on the
lecture circuit on the fact you know but
yeah she lives in Alaska and a lot of
Russian presence in Alaska they're the
ones we got alaska from we actually
thought it was a bad deal when we first
bought it they call it C words folly
because he was the guy who organized the
to sail the Russians have been there for
you know several hundred years and they
did mission work and they established an
orthodox presence in Alaska they
actually did mission work to a lot of
the Native Americans there that lasted
for quite some time so once if we put a
laska out of it and we look mainly at
the immigration coming in through the
East we have all these groups settling
down in different places your book talks
in particular about the Russians and
about the Greeks because those are the
largest groups in the United States
those are the ones that
dominate Orthodox in the United States
so it says during the years following
the Civil War Eastern Orthodox
immigrants again settle they generally
worship at Russian founded parishes the
Russians were the ones who came in first
quite often and then as you know say
Serbians or vulgarians would come in
they would take over that parish and
begin doing the liturgy in that language
and but they kept a lot of those you
know the same practices because all of
them are sharing the same basic body of
beliefs and practices all the dumb icons
all of them have the same you know take
mass just you know so many different
languages so the Russian leadership like
says welcome this expression of what
they call pan orthodoxy so that's a good
word to put down and orthodoxy what does
that mean any times you can what should
you think frying pan but pref expand
yeah exactly yeah means all literally
and Greek so yeah it's going to be a
wide spectrum they're all more or less
on the same page so they were willing to
appoint priests of other backgrounds to
positions of responsibility the Greeks
however are a little bit different they
prefer to worship in their own familiar
languages and traditions and so we get
this this diversity within the Orthodox
community yeah and your book talks about
a number of the sort of ways in which
these panned out spends a little bit of
time talking about the Greeks and I
suppose it's good to dwell on this it
might seem a little bit of trivia but
what a good with the Greeks what
industry did the Greeks really make it
big in anyone know still leaves a mark
today the restaurant business
a lot of Italian restaurants now to tell
you know they're actually Grieco
throughout the entire United States
there's a sort of you know restaurants
are one of the one of the businesses
that you can open up without an awful
lot of working capital and once you make
it you can go sell it to somebody else
and start doing more restaurants so
Greece end up you know becoming
restaurant tours confectionery
stationers there's all sorts of ethnic
towns that arise because of this Greek
towns Russian towns and your book also
talks about one other thing it's kind of
an interesting bit of the story unit
Christians or unit Catholics were
members of these groups who in the old
country had left the Orthodox Church and
become Catholic and usually a large
groups when they come over to America
one of the things that tended to turn
them off was you know they had with the
unit Catholics in other places like in
Ukraine for example Ukraine you know
that for a long time part of Russia
right but a lot of Ukrainians became
unit Catholics and what that meant was
they were allowed to keep their liturgy
they were allowed to continue on with
their rituals their practices they
didn't have to conform to the Roman
right when they came here to the United
States a lot of them were told will know
you're not going to be able to do that
anymore so they actually reconverted and
became Orthodox some of them still are
you know within the Catholic Church
talk about that the Russian story is a
little bit complicated because of one of
that what's the that's the key event
that raises all sorts of Proverbs
remember russia russian orthodoxy you
don't have a separation of church and
state so you know the bishop or the
patriarchs and the rulers are closely
connected with each other what happens
in russia in 1917 yeah yeah so why is
that important you have a revolution who
takes over the Russian Revolution
prevention I don't mean at the very
start I know that it's complicated
there's a provisional government by any
lexie 1919-20 who he has power in Russia
holds on to it till about 1989 yeah
communism right is really no place
religion on this country yeah now the
Russian Orthodox Church didn't hold its
doors and the patriarch of Moscow is now
in hostile territory he's the head of
the church so you know you might say
well can you actually follow him now
because he's going to be ruled by these
communists and they're going to use him
as a tool as a matter of fact they
didn't get rid of the Russian Orthodox
Church they they began appointing your
own bishops and they would be bishops
who are okay with communism and we were
going to
along with the party line so that leads
to some some real issues like it says
the pressing question is whether
continuing allegiance to Moscow as
possible in a situation where an
anti-religious communist regime now
control the patriarchy so one one
solution that is what's called the
Orthodox Church in America these were
Russian Orthodox who is where most of
the Russian Orthodox went they they
became their own independent Church they
were ethnically russian but they no
longer took their cues from the Russian
Orthodox Church in the homeland the way
that the the others were doing and they
became what was called autocephalous
that means that they have their own head
they have a patriarch in in America
they're like it says their headquarters
is in Syosset New York and they have
nine diocese they have their own
seminaries and they produced a lot of
important theologians then there was the
patriarchal parishes of the Russian
Orthodox Church in united's in canada
i'm just going to abbreviate that agent
miracle parishes the Russian Orthodox
Church in the United States and Canada
these are ones who maintain direct ties
of Moscow there's never been a lot of
them and then there was the what's
called the russian orthodox church
outside of Russia so the Russian
community gets split into several
different groups they didn't acknowledge
the Moscow leadership in any way these
guys eventually reconciled with the
Moscow leadership and that's the main
split between them notice that that all
of them have seminaries in New York the
largest church besides now for the docs
church
erica is the Greek Orthodox Church in
the United States because the greens
were the largest set of immigrants and
like says there were a lot of splits
within the community but they never
actually became full schisms it tells
you about their their seven areas as
well and then it talks about a number of
other groups the Albanians antiochian
Bulgarian Romanian Ruthenian Serbian
Ukrainian branches just for some all of
these are Orthodox and all of these are
continuing the same traditions bless you
now one of the other things that your
book talks about this particularly
important is that there's been a lot of
conversions in recent years to orthodoxy
why would people be attracted to Eastern
Orthodoxy a lot of people are born into
it now if you're if you're Greek odds
are if your family is religious at all
you're probably a Greek Orthodox
Christian I mean you'll probably stick
with that unless you decide you want to
become a Baptist or Methodist our
Catholic something along those maybe
convert to Islam right where are they
going to get Congress from why would
people convert to Eastern Orthodox think
about it you know all that it entails
Eastern Orthodox services how long do
you think a regular you know likes a
catholic church service runs how long
usually would you say not Christmastime
or Easter yeah that's known as 45
minutes left like that if it goes beyond
the ad quite off of the priest will get
chewed out what are you doing now where
the dark services are a bit longer than
that there's a lot more going on what
else do you remember about some of the
key differences remember about the
account of status and the
the consecration of the bread of the
line actually happens behind the wall of
the the icon things are slower tends to
be a lot of incense a lot of things
going on why would people be attracted
to that what are they looking for do you
think what could you imagine they want
from that number of Protestant
theologians in recent years is converted
them come Eastern Orthodox they're
attracted to ritual they're attracted to
these practices that have deep and
lasting significance that people have
been doing for centuries and sometimes
even millennia they're attracted to
becoming part of this you know ongoing
community so that's something that
that's been going on and like your book
says that creates tensions because you
know how it is in any group you've got
people who are sort of like just born
into the group and they get people who
come in from the outside of a little bit
more on fire they're a little bit more
into it they don't always get along do
that the people who were there before
like hey well you know you're an
outsider who are you to tell us you know
what we want to be doing people coming
in from the outside Iran with our often
looking at the people who are born into
and saying well you're really not into
this re why even bother and you know it
leads to some some conflicts from time
to time so that's one attention that
that's going on another issue is
intermarriage here in the United States
especially today if you're worth it ox
odds are you you're you have a good
chance of marrying somebody who's not
Orthodox and then the question is which
church are you go to are you going to
keep going to church you know which are
you going to bring the children to
orthodoxy is one of those those sorts of
things where because
is tied in with that ethnicity
intermarriage is seen as is possibly
diluting it or possibly enriching
depending on how you how you look at it